We are now hearing from more and more politicians
that they want a $15 minimum wage.
Wouldn't this cause inflation?
So here's what you have to understand about
a question like the $15 minimum wage.
Um, every policy that is put in place has
um, items on both sides of the ledger.
We've said wouldn't Medicare for all killed
jobs?
Yes, it would kill some jobs.
It would create others.
It would increase.
Uh, the, the, the net benefit I believe is
very clear for Medicare for all, but it would
kill some jobs and that's not a reason not
to do it.
That's a reason to figure out the way to do
it the right way.
If you talk about increasing the minimum wage,
minimum wage increases to some degree can
accelerate price inflation.
The problem is that that is a talking point
being used by the right to just oppose even
common sense increases to the minimum wage.
The minimum wage has fallen way behind inflation.
It has fallen way behind productivity.
There is no index that justifies as low a
minimum wage as that which we have now.
And the reality is that labor costs are only
part of a businesses total costs.
So there have been studies done which suggest
if McDonald's, I don't remember the study
exactly, but the idea was if McDonald's goes
to a whatever, minimum wage, 12 $15, whatever,
that would be a significant raise for a lot
of employees.
But you could match that by increasing the
cost of a big Mac by 10 cents because averaged
into all or that all of that are fixed costs,
rent, food costs, transportation, executive
salaries, connectivity, and it systems, all
of this different stuff.
So yes, the w when you increase a minimum
wage, there can be an inflationary effect,
but that doesn't mean we should be scared.
If you are increasing the buying power of
so many employees, demand side stimulus, making
them better able to afford their lives, they
have disposable income to go and spend in
their communities, which has an economic multiplier
effect.
The small inflationary effect on the price
of, for example, food at McDonald's in order
to give everybody a meaningful raise is a
very valid and palatable trade to be made.
So when we get these black and white questions
isn't a $15 minimum wage bad because it'll
cause inflation.
The question needs to be how much inflation
will it cost and how does that relate to the
overarching cost of living in these areas?
And that's where I've read increasingly very
good economic analysis, which say $15 minimum
wage is probably too low in some high cost
of living places, but it may be too high in
some other places in low cost of living parts
of the country, uh, with a much lower current
minimum wage, going to 15 could double the
minimum wage that may be out of line with
what the local economy, uh, needs or what
the local, uh, economic parameters dictate.
That's not me being against the $15 minimum
wage and some places it should be 22.
When you look at cost of living, this is me
saying that any one size fits all black white
thinking about this issue is likely to be
wrong.
And we have to look at all of these issues
in more detail.
Any policy has an upside and a downside and
economics.
The science of economics done well.
Um, and economic analysis can tell us when
the benefit outweighs the cost for the broader
betterment of society.
Let me know what you think.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Don't miss it.
Become a member at [inaudible].
Join pacman.com or become a patron at patrion.com/david
Pakman show to get instant access to today's
bonus show, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].